- Whether you've been aware of it or not,
your brain has been telling you
a story about your own life.
It's been telling you a
story about who you are,
what your personality is like,
what your strengths and weaknesses are,
how likely you are to
stick to certain habits,
and how easily you give up
on taking care of yourself.
Maybe it's been telling you a story
about how success and happiness
are for other people, not you.
You're kind of doomed to
repeat your same old mistakes.
You're not very good
at sticking to habits.
You don't really commit
to changing your life
for the better.
Maybe the life that you thought
is the one that you wanted to live,
just isn't in the cards for you.
Maybe your brain has been telling you
that you're a shy person,
or an extroverted person.
Maybe it's been telling you
that you suck at public speaking
and you get way too nervous.
And you would never do that.
You could never speak in
front of thousands of people.
Some people are extremely
aware of the fact
that their brain tells
them certain stories.
Other people live their life
kind of oblivious to this.
They just think that things
are the way that they are.
They think the way that they
think they believe the things
that they believe.
And this is actually kind of
a problem for a lot of people
if you remain unaware of
the fact that your brain
is constantly crafting a
narrative about your life,
your tendencies, the people around you,
and the role that you
play in the universe.
And we can't escape these stories forming,
it's because our subconscious
is extremely perceptive.
Your subconscious picks up
on basically everything.
I've mentioned on this channel before
that over 90% of our
overall mental function
is subconscious.
That's kind of the consensus
for psychologists these days.
Bottom line is that we
are constantly observing,
picking up and taking note
of every sight and smell,
every taste and texture,
everything that everyone says about you,
either in front of your
face or behind your back,
every small success and bitter failure
is woven into this story
that you tell yourself
about yourself.
And we believe this story.
You know, we kind of have no choice.
We have to pick up on patterns
otherwise the world seems too chaotic.
But I think the problem is that
what we think happened often
isn't what actually happened.
We are a highly emotional creatures.
We interpret things with
a lot of subjectivity,
and a lot of these opinions were formed
when we were so young that
we didn't even really have
the ability to think rationally.
You know, if your older
brother decides to play
with the cool kid on the
block instead of you,
as the younger brother, you
might feel really left out
and you might think that nobody likes you
or nobody cares about you.
And if a couple more situations
like this start to happen,
it can really start to develop a belief
that you are not worth hanging out with.
You know, no one really likes you.
You're not worthy of love.
And you'll carry that with you
subconsciously through life,
having no idea that that belief
is there or why it's there,
but it will serve as sort of
a fundamental character trait
woven into your story.
And it gets even trickier
because human beings
really like to stay
consistent with this story
since it is the fundamental framework,
the lens in which we view the world
and make sense of things
so things don't seem so utterly chaotic.
When new information is provided to us
that contradicts that
story, we tend to reject it.
We will throw out new
information in favor of ideas
that help confirm our cognitive bias,
things in line with the
story that we've always told.
And that really sucks
because a lot of the time,
a lot of the time, the
stories we tell ourselves
don't serve us.
We might think it serves
us because we think
it's the truth because
we haven't questioned it.
But the proof of its
efficacy is in the pudding.
You know, if you're not
where you want to be in life,
if you feel unsatisfied
on a day-to-day basis,
if you don't have a sense of
inner peace or satisfaction
with what you do or the state of the world
or the state of yourself,
there's a good chance that
your story isn't serving you.
So what's the solution?
Well, thankfully, there's this
thing called Neuroplasticity,
which is kind of a general umbrella term
that refers to the brain's
ability to modify change
and adapt both structure
and function throughout life
and in response to experience.
And if you think about it,
this is probably the most
optimistic psychological discovery
in history for people who
don't really like the way
that they behave, or the thought patterns
that they tend to dive into.
And that's because by
introducing new stimulus
or getting new experiences or
behaving in a different way
over time can actually
change the literal structure
of your brain so that those
changes become permanent.
You can redesign your brain in
a way that better serves you.
And really the only thing stopping you
is cognitive bias and
cognitive dissonance.
And the fact that to
behave in a different way,
in a way that isn't the way
that you've always acted,
it's gonna feel uncomfortable.
It's gonna feel unnatural.
It's gonna feel like it's not really you
doing these things.
But I can guarantee you
that if you do these things long enough,
it's not just some sort of
overused empty platitude
that these things will
start to feel more natural.
They will. Those things
will start to feel like you.
By doing these things over
a long period of time,
your subconscious that is always watching
starts to actually develop
evidence that you are this way.
By acting in this new way,
in the present moment,
day after day, eventually
that present becomes the past.
And when your subconscious
looks over your life,
you have evidence from
the past and the present
of this new behavior in this new lifestyle
and it can predict and assume confidently
that you are capable of
continuing this lifestyle
and you are capable of change
going on into the future.
So it all starts with awareness.
It all starts by taking a step
back and trying to figure out
what story your brain is
telling yourself about yourself?
Who are you according to you?
What things do you usually do?
And what behaviors do
you engage in day to day
that reaffirms that belief?
And how can you modify those behaviors
to better serve you so
that when your subconscious
naturally does its thing
and observes your behavior,
it has some evidence to go off
of that you are indeed this new person,
you are indeed the
person that you actually
intentionally want to be this time,
rather than the person
that you kind of ended up
as by accident.
Since the beginning of time,
human beings have used stories
to help them make sense
of the world around them.
We are compelled by stories
when someone tells a funny joke,
or when we all flocked
to the movie theater
to see the new Spider-Man.
And for that reason, I
highly recommend the book,
"The Science of
Storytelling" by Will Storr.
I'm currently listening
to this gem on Audible,
which is today's video sponsor.
And it's helping me realize
that there's an actual formula
to storytelling.
So if you're interested in
being a more engaging speaker,
you just wanna tell funnier
jokes at the dinner table,
or maybe you wanna get
into creative writing
or script writing,
check out this incredible audiobook
and all of the other amazing audiobooks
that you can find on Audible.
For those of you who don't know,
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
and audiobooks, all in one place.
If you're into self-improvement,
you're interested in
productivity and philosophy,
or even if you just want
to engage with inspiring
and enriching ideas
that will help you grow,
Audible is kind of a no-brainer.
As an Audible member, every single month
you receive one credit which
you can spend on any audiobook
of your choice regardless of cost.
And you also get access to
a rapidly expanding catalog
of Audible Originals,
podcasts, and exclusive series.
And another great thing
is that once you download
an audiobook, whether you
paid for it or got it for free
using their credit system,
you get to keep that audiobook forever.
If you ever cancel your membership,
you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks.
So if you're interested in signing up,
you get a 30 day free trial
if you use my link in
the description below,
or just text "betterideas" to 500-500.
So yeah, take advantage of that link.
Use my link in the description below,
or text "betterideas" to 500-500
to sign up for your 30 day free trial.
Listen to "The Science of
Storytelling" by Will Storr.
Expand your mind, learn something new.
And as usual, have a great time.
I forgot to film an outro.
If you liked this video, hit Like,
like, actually click the Like button
because it does wonders for the algorithm.
I really need the views. I'm dying.
I feel loopy right now, guys.
I've been editing this video.
So we got hit by COVID.
I got hit by COVID pretty hard.
And we've been dealing
with COVID this month
so we got a last minute rush
at the end of this month.
That's why there's two videos back to back
because I'm just working
overtime here editing this.
I forgot to do an outro.
And I am mentally stable,
very mentally stable.
I'm thriving, actually.
Subscribe to the channel
if you haven't already.
And maybe subscribe to the second channel.
Yeah, maybe do that.
Have a good one guys.
At this point, I'm just
like cranking the watch time
of this video, because I don't think
this video is long enough.
Yeah, just trying to
soak in that Ad Sense.
It's not awkward if you
don't make it awkward.
I'm perfectly comfortable with silence
and I'm perfectly comfortable
with being cringe.
I'm fully aware of the
cringe levels right now.
There's cringe off the
charts, some might say.
Is that, oh yeah, so we're at 10 minutes.
All right. Catch you in the next video.